foreign
Mike is in Madison Wisconsin hey Mike
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and Ken appreciate you taking my
call sure what's up
yeah um so I have been listening for
about two years uh first time caller
though and uh the reason I'm calling is
that currently I am on baby step four
five and six
um I'm an engineer and I heard you
talking about that before so I really
think about the numbers and as far as uh
you know becoming everyday millionaire
and whatnot
um my wife and I have one three and a
half year old son right now and we
currently pay 305 a week for daycare so
that's a pretty big bite on the budget
we have no other debt besides uh the
house the mortgage and it's no student
loans no credit card debts or anything
of that sort doing great uh we are yeah
thank you uh we are floating the idea of
another child but when I do my budgets
we are about twelve hundred dollars
Surplus every month for a normal month
uh that doesn't include if you know
Carney's tires or if the washing machine
you know clunks out or whatever it may
be so an infant daycare is going to be
more than 300 a week like my three and a
half year old is now because he is potty
trained so I'm like struggling with the
idea of cutting my Surplus each month
down to zero or even negative
1200 to add a newborn to daycare
it sure as heck does I pay 305 a week
right now for a three and a half year
old
and you're gonna it's gonna be 1500 now
a month
uh it would be I would say it'd probably
be you know somewhere around 1300 a
month for a newborn
or a three-month-old anyway after the
journey leaves okay all right then
you're gonna have to look for
um other because you're you're now at uh
you're you're now paying the daycare
more than you guys make
um
that's what you're telling me
uh well 1200 a month Surplus
yeah after after bills are paid uh we
might not counted a new baby going to
daycare
and we're not yeah we're not pregnant or
anything we're all floating the idea of
it and you know right now we're at 1200
Surplus but if we were to have a baby
you know say 10 months from now uh and
put the baby in daycare you know it's
daycare then we would be negative so you
and I are spending all this time
worrying about a hypothetical
correct okay now we're not gonna worry
about hypotheticals dude
[Laughter]
I mean it's wise to plan but you're over
analyzing and everything just calm down
you're going to be making more money
you're gonna have to find a different
day care if you literally have no money
left after paying daycare then that
means you've got too expensive a daycare
you got to do something different and
you're going to try to find a different
situation when and if you have a second
child but I don't think we need to worry
about this today that's right and I I
will just I'll just add practically uh
when When Stacy and I uh when our three
kids were younger we looked at daycare
and in the area where we lived in North
Georgia it was really really expensive
and we ran up against this thing and to
what Dave said can be done and I'll just
point out that we said well daycare is
not an option so you know we did we
started talking to everybody we knew hey
does anybody know a Grandmama who wants
to work a little bit wants to make a
little extra spending cash you trust her
she's got grandbabies she's retired and
we found the right people and so we
found daycare in the form of an awesome
Christian grandmother who came in and
took care of the kids while Stacy and I
worked and it was a fraction she was
thrilled we were thrilled where there's
a will there's a way you don't have to
just rely on what has become an enormous
expense it is admittedly very large
expansion yeah yeah and so but uh I also
don't spend I'm not going to burn a
whole lot of calories on stuff that
might happen something that's correct so
we're going to work about you know when
God says that babies have babies the
best thing you can do on the planet is
babies babies are awesome
and the only thing better than babies or
grandbabies
and so um if I'd known how great
grandbabies are going to be I'd have
been nicer to their parents yeah you get
all the fun stuff and then you get to
send them home well I had Daniel's last
night and he was he was kind of having a
hard time about about uh you know uh uh
bedtime or whatever right and I actually
had this shirt on and I went to come out
here and I looked down there's baby snot
all over the side of the shirt I had to
wipe it all off before I got out here a
while ago I had to get the had to get
the damp cloth out and get the Eli snot
off there it is there we go hazards of
being Papa Dave That's it man but um you
know I and I can tell you this we didn't
charge them near enough for keeping I
bet she did
they got a deal
yeah you're gonna figure it out as you
go my man and you're a good man for
thinking about it you're a good dad for
planning ahead but don't plan so far
ahead that you live in worry